[Music]
the main
objective is to save the world with
creativity
the idea is use visual communication and
the tricks of
advertising and try and infuse it into
education
and you take something from a highly
creative industry
and use its effectiveness and its
ability to affect
change that sort of stuff is really
strong and provocative and i think
that's exactly
what is needed to inspire the change
that's needed for the next generation
ten years ago with cult magazine we work
with artists and designers
who are really skilled at evoking
emotions or illustrating facts based on
themes like trust
fear and we touched slightly on social
issues
but it was quite a niche audience and we
wanted to reach a much broader audience
and bring art and design and we felt it
the right way to go was to start in
in education so our first issue was on
the dangers of the internet
and we didn't know where it would go but
then we started seeing a lot of art
teachers coming to our exhibitions and
saying they were using it as a tool to
start discussion in the classroom
and beyond singapore we're we're also
excited that the
content has reached the uk the us hong
kong taiwan in a world where there's
so much imagery and and so much noise
how do we cut through
all that so i think by using schools and
sort of educational
approach we can tell people to analyze
images in a different context and be
more careful about how they read images
so i has designed around this visual
trigger
to trigger a conversation or a
discussion in a classroom
it also encourages them to look a bit
deeper and harder into
the details of an image that only reveal
themselves on a second viewing so i
think it's both of those things it's
revealing hidden messages but it's also
training a sort of visual literacy
we as parents i feel that children need
to know about things like internet
safety
and healthy eating and sustainability
and mental wellness and financial
literacy
we feel those topics are really
important and combining the powerful
visuals
with those really highly relevant but
sometimes
sensitive and complex topics serves as
the inspiration behind ayah
you